what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to
Pearl daily where I cover this week's
treachery debauchery and craziness
before I start don't forget to subscribe
to the channel and bring that
notification Bell that way you're going
to be notified of my daily videos like
the video on your way in and get
yourself a women shouldn't vote t-shirt
today as you guys know all of the
craziness in the world started when
women got the right to vote I was
actually researching the
anti-suffragists the other day and they
equated it to Communism and said if
women get the right to vote basically
we're going to have communism in a
hundred years and look where we are
today so guys let's work to move this
Overton window these ideas sound crazy
until you really research them and start
thinking about them so when you have
these shirts on it's actually a really
good conversation starter in public um I
know a lot of you think people will hit
you or whatever and I I give you zero
promises I I promise nothing but usually
they're more Curious than anything and
then you can yeah then you have a
conversation anyways um all right guys
make sure you like the video on your way
in so my first story today is from a
girl named Sarah Safari and Bradley
Martin so they have a podcast together
it's called Mommy and Daddy talk now
Sarah Safari is a very dedicated
bodybuilder and so she has kind of made
a name for herself making content with
Bradley and she's sort of like the funny
I don't know girl next door in the gym I
guess maybe
and so Sarah does a lot of bodybuilding
a lot of streaming those are primarily
male dominated spaces and there was a
video of her that was going viral let's
show it picture with a guy and I post on
my Snapchat because I take pictures with
anything and everything but I'm
saying it gets put on Twitter and it's
like oh she's getting passed like she's
getting passed around like a blunt and
it's like they assume that just that
picture with the guy means that we're
sleeping together is the whole this is
the whole Nina AGD doll thing yes it's
yeah it is even though it's all content
even like yesterday with Bryce um Bryce
got down on one KNE pretending to
propose right Mah was there he saw the
whole thing pretending to propose and we
were like oh that's a good um that's
good content for Snapchat like as the
clickbait right and that's all it was
and then we both got up and we left
right like we sat down did the picture
for 10 seconds and then that was that
but then people assume oh they're
sleeping together she gets passed around
or like sneak go a cuck because he's let
he's watching like Bryce I'm like it's
literally content it's there's nothing
more to it than we thought it'd be a
good thumbnail and then it was so her
complaint basically was I'm not sleeping
with these guys but every time I take a
picture with any of these guys or I'm
working around these guys everyone
assumes I've been a past around and then
I'm a [__] that's her complaint and
really she's just never been told how
men think and when you're around guys
all the time and you're dressing half
naked which is kind of inevitable in
bodybuilding you know that's that's what
people are going to assume and life is
about choices and tradeoffs and if
that's what you want to do that's
totally fine but the trade-off is that
that is what people are going to assume
so I said the reason being that when
you're around a bunch of men and
dressing half naked in front of a bunch
of guys men will make assumptions the
same way if someone dressed like a
homeless person and around homeless
people it will be assumed that the
person person is homeless it does
decrease your value to men to be
constantly receiving attention from
other men and you know guys this is true
life is about choices and trade-offs and
if you choose to go in that into that
industry you can't have it all and so
many times we tell women yes you can be
around all of these guys take pictures
around all of these guys and nobody will
make assumptions about you guys I'm not
even saying it's right or it's wrong I'm
saying this is what is going to happen
and choose accordingly the other thing
is if it's not true I wouldn't worry so
much about it because you can't really
help what the internet says I've had
crazy things said about me on the
internet but why freak out or why do a
whole podcast about it if it doesn't
bother you so to me it seems like
something like struck a cord with her I
don't know what but yeah this is this is
how men think guys and ladies if if you
want to be around a bunch of guys all
the time that men are just going to
assume that something's happened with
one of them but you know that's the
trade-off she gets to make a lot of
money off of YouTube which is amazing
she has an awesome career she gets to do
all of these really cool things and the
tradeoff is you know sometimes people
are going to assume things but if you if
you know it's not true who cares who
cares what they say okay and the
influencer space guys really can be
unstable just like the economy right now
geopolitical tensions are escalating
inflation is Raging and despite what
they say stocks are sinking and debt is
rising and your own financial future
isn't looking too clever yet gold
endures every crisis Wars disasters no
Calamity has beat gold while paper
assets crash burn golden doors every
single time you need to take a fresh
look at gold studying your portfolio
right now and get a free 5 oce America
the Beautiful gold coin when you open an
IRA with Noble gold Investments today
Shield your savings with Noble gold
Investments go to Noble gold
investments.com that's noblegold
investments.com the only gold company
that I trust so the comment said dress
classy to get married dress sexy to get
laid dress trashy to make money women
have the power not the men yes and that
was my whole point you can't choose to
go in this career path and then cry
about the outcomes later the other funny
thing was I was thinking the solution is
to
maybe stop taking pictures with a bunch
of
men or don't and keep doing it and
they'll keep saying the same things and
make your money you know again life is
about choices and tradeoffs um Canan
says she's bragging about intentionally
deceiving men and women by using her
body and men's intentions as a bait
criticism said why do Western women want
to look like
men you know I actually I
don't it'll be interesting what you guys
think in the comments I don't think she
looks like a guy when she's just
normally talking I just think it's some
of the posed stuff um okay but anyways
speaking of women that are overloaded on
attention as you guys know attention is
to women as to sex is to men so a lot of
times getting a bunch of sexual
attention just messes up us up
especially from a young age so a couple
of days ago I covered an NBA star Joe
Smith's wife starting an only fan so she
was just taunting him she had the camera
out and she was saying yes I had to
start an only fans I was like this when
you met me so now she's actually crying
that he left her let's pull up the video
first question is where's Jo are you how
are you guys doing where's
Joe um he's pretty pissed off with me so
he's been um I think he's at his
sister's house he's not talking to me
right now so yeah Kesha how long ago
obviously we saw in the video that Joe's
saying had no idea that you had this
account how long how long is the account
have you had the
page um I've had the page for at least
over a year um it's on my Instagram in
my LinkedIn but that's what happens when
you don't pay attention to your wife
period um and you know he has a friend
that he's been entertaining and she
decided that you know she wants to
really put a wrench a bigger you know
wedge in our relationship so she went
digging around my page and was like oh
do you know that she has this and it
blew it from that it's no secret Joe's
Financial issues you know and I have
always made a good life for myself you
know um before I met Joe I was living
overseas in Europe and I had established
myself as a singer you know and I came
back here you know thinking that with
his Persona and who he was once we got
together and I found out who he was that
it would only take off you know other
things but you know not everybody's
hustle and drive are the same and
depression is a serious thing also so
you know I've been just like you know
supporting and dealing and going through
his trials and tribulations with him um
I've started several businesses you know
i' I've been doing a lot like and I just
was I just figured out like figure I
have a home in Cap bird I'm trying not
to lose and a and a roof over here we're
trying to maintain that we almost got
kicked out of so I just kicked in the
drive and did what I had to do you know
and he won't do it so I had to and I'm
sorry you knew I was an adult video star
when you met me so if my survival if I
would do anything for my own Survival
then what makes you think that would
change now when I retired from the adult
industry I promised myself if I don't
sing I don't eat so when you know my
music career wasn't popping here when I
left Germany and I stayed here for him I
figured you
know I would you know start a business I
started a puppy friend Social Club
business the dog sitting business and
then coid happened and that screwed
everything up I have a a moving company
you know that he actually works for me
like he works for my moving company you
know I'm tired of being the one to
figure [__] out so
I figured it out the best way I know
that can maximize the money that needs
to come in because I'm tired of living
like you know I'm tired of living
minimal you know it's not it's not fair
and I don't understand how you could
have had such a Maximized Life and be so
content this is ridiculous but we've
been together for almost 13 years though
we've been together since 2012 like
after his retirement and it really
wasn't a retirement that he wanted it
was a forced retirement because he just
got locked out after the lockout in the
2011 lockout you guys remember you know
he just never got a new job nobody
wanted him anymore so you know there was
a depression and I've been going you
know dealing with all of this stuff and
I'm sorry you know I that I I'm not
sorry for what I'm doing I'm just sorry
that he can't understand that it's not
that wasn't a selfish um decision it was
a decision that I made I made an
executive decision when my man wasn't
taking the lead I really love Joe um I
just I love him um if we were like if he
never speaks to me again I still will do
things to help him or whatever I can
because he's my family you know he's
like an intricate part of my life and I
just want the best for
us I wish he wanted that also that's
really where I'm at you know I wish that
he wanted the best for us because he's
not really wanting the best for himself
so I can't expect him to do for him what
he for me what he can't do for himself I
guess and that's why I just did what I
had to do have you drawn that Line in
the Sand that you will continue doing
only fans unless something else happens
that you know changes that no I'm going
to continue my only fans I think as a
couple and just him individually he
needs counseling to help find out how to
refind himself and find his new place in
the world you know it's really hard once
you've had a major career you were this
number one draft pick and then
everything ends you know how do you you
deal with that I don't want to be alone
but you
know if that's what it has to be that's
what it has to be but um I I I I don't
think we'll have a divorce I don't think
so I think he'll I think he he'll come
around there are very few videos that
leave me speechless that that is the
most delusional woman I have ever seen
in my life I took a couple notes so she
how did she have an only fans account
for over a year and he didn't notice
nobody told him number that's like
question number one that I have this is
what she
says this is what happens when you don't
pay attention to your
wife but also says she is tired of
living
minimally whatever the hell that means
she says with a face full of makeup
nails and fake
hair do these [__] even know what
minimal
means go to go to a third world country
for a oh my spend like a day spend a day
in India I I you can see what living
minimally means oh my okay and then on
top of that she goes forward and discuss
his Private Financial
issues and points out that she used to
be a traveler and
Entertainer and they're living
minimally and she says as she starts an
only fans that she is the Hustler and
has the drive in the
relationship she says she's tired of
being the one
hustling while her ex was a major NBA
star she as a hooker is tired of being
the hustle you can't make this [__]
up oh
my and her businesses
include dog sitting in a moving
company can you imagine your wife is
like hey honey I started this moving
company can you help me oh sure
honey and then she goes out and says he
works for me I'm the Hustler
are you the one moving everything does
that does that strike you as a woman
that's really
GNA and this is why really men should
avoid actresses social media Stars
singers any type of sex work because
again and I'm glad that we actually you
know these women tell on themselves now
she says if I did once for my survival
because they see hair nails makeup all
that [__] as survival why wouldn't I do
it again and men think the same thing
and that is why they don't date hookers
okay so let's look at the comments
instead of repairing y'all marriage in
private you went on TMZ to bash him and
play victim
yes it's crazy that even being dead
wrong she is still the victim make it
make sense yeah I don't like this starts
crying proof that you got to let a hoe
be a hoe they will never change yes yes
yes yes you cannot come back from only
fans these women do not get married they
do not stay married and they eventually
typically break up and you really do see
the life cycle of these guys um that
marry sex workers and only fans models
and really just attention addicted women
um and that's why in general as a
general rule really men should avoid
social media Stars actresses any type of
sex work it is a bad idea it is it is
bad you do not want those types of
chicks um and you see what's going on
with the younger guys where their pool
of women is so diluted that they're
actually considering and dating women
with only fans it's a general problem
with the most attractive women so neon
is a young streamer and he does streams
with Bradley Martin I've seen him do
stuff with a blue face um I've seen him
I even just saw a clip of him with
Charlie demilio the other day um and
really he he's probably worth millions
and millions of dollars as a young kid
and he decided
to wife up and only fans model and they
sort of went viral in the last couple of
weeks because she took a lie detector
test and she said she has not seen
anybody since they've been talking and
that she has been celibate you know
there's been other Clips going viral
basically saying that she is not
sleeping with him but she is on only
fans and now it's coming out that neon
tells Aiden Ross that he believes his
girlfriend when she said she slept in
the same bed as another guy and didn't
have sex with him let's pull it
up but I I basically just said today
that Sam flew on a guy in Vegas and they
um during when rice [__] got swatted and
then they had breakfast that morning
together and I just wanted to know man
you know neon is texting my phone saying
dude Aiden I promise you they didn't
they just slept together you know what
I'm saying and I think that's he's being
in denial um because obvious she's like
don't worry we didn't [__] we didn't
[__] we just slept together and you know
whether they were serious or not chat
it's still red flag s go I want to know
your take on that whole thing I know
okay um yeah look so we both know that's
[__] like a girl says that like
you're not flying a dude if a girl's
flying a dude out when I fly a chick out
I expect [__] if I'm gonna guys like
myON took a lot of heat cuz and I
actually when I first heard this I was
sort of triggered too but he he had a
clip that went viral and he said if a
girl doesn't sleep with you on the first
SE I think it was first second date
maybe even first date he said tell her
to get out and the reason being is men
don't want to be dragged around like
this they don't want to find out later
that the girl they're seeing that made
them wait hopped right into bed and even
flew out another guy and that's you know
and I as a girl I I know girls will come
in and they'll say you have a right to
say no and you totally do but this is
just how men see it and I don't know why
he's really taking an only fans model
seriously it kind of brings him in views
so you know whatever I guess there's one
more video's pull it up this is where
the tradcon
advice and I don't say this in a happy
way guys I don't say this like I'm super
happy about it but I really want you to
see more where some of these pickup guys
are coming from the reason they say
things like you need to have sex with
her as soon as possible the reason
they don't really have a lot of patience
in that department is stuff like this
because women will drag these guys
around women with more sexual experience
that know the game better than the guys
and take advantage of men that do not
know better and you know men are kind of
sick of being taken advantage of um but
unfortunately I do think this is kind of
the future now let's look at the
comments they said if we're being real
neon corny for just sitting there and
let some other dude speak for his
relationship he fried her
though next comment says they forgot to
include
22 no um British homie is a real man
standing up for a fellow man being taken
advantage of mad respect Albi the entire
situation is a bit stupid in the first
place so you know neon's free to choose
what he wants to do um and I I think
eventually these relationships when
they're younger they don't last anyways
um but I I do you know there's
consequences when you date an only fans
model and the past will always come back
to haunt you to if she's willing to do
it once why would she not do it
again I was scrolling on Twitter so you
guys know I love Twitter and I saw this
clip of a woman named Katie H Hopkins
and Katie Hopkins is a British
politician um and she was on SAS cast
like a year ago and it's funny because I
I don't know Katie but I know a couple
people that have interviewed her around
here and I also have been on SAS cast so
I know Adam so I just thought this clip
was so funny pull it up yeah but I I
hear you on that yep quick thought for
you um we're living in an attention
economy eyeballs are everything these
days and kudos to you because you're a
brilliant talker you know what you're
saying you're a shock jock like you're a
Howard Stern esque type person and some
of the things you say are hyperbolic
some of the things you say are true not
everything is everything for you um I'm
wondering for you what percentage are
you saying just to as a comedian to be
hyperbolic and just to kind of throw
stuff out out there and what stuff is
actually factual and true so for
instance I have a phone in my hand this
is a phone and you can Google things
with a phone so um Vladimir zalinski a
couple quick points he's the same height
as your boy Putin they're both 5'7 he's
not 5'4 Putin isn't exactly a giant okay
that's one number two I don't give two
shits about the Muslims in the UK but a
quick Google search will show you that
Muslims population will double by 2030
apparently and go from
6.3% to 17 % by 2050 this is Google
Katie I don't care thirdly I just
Googled pictures of UK police officers
with guns apparently they got a lot of
[__] guns so my question to you is
what percentage of what you're saying is
hyperbolic getting eyeballs respect we
live in that kind of world Now versus
actually factual and true okay uh let's
go from the start there you showing me
what a phone is and saying this is a
phone that isn't really the way to start
an argument because that's to assert
that I'm stupid and don't know what a
phone is well you're assuming we're
stupid because we can't Google things
that you say as a fact would you like me
to answer what you just said going to
talk over me we could do either one I
could go either way so but go ahead this
is all you is it yeah go ahead so
starting off on that kind of tone I
don't think is necessary you then go to
your phone and say I can Google this
like you've got the biggest penis on the
planet where you might have the biggest
penis on the planet Kitty I don't know
darling I've got bigger balls Caitlyn
Jenner I I actually believe you Katie I
actually believe you goad you're so bad
at listening and then when you stop
talking you say go ahead for just a
moment in time you can Google anything
why don't you Google my name and see
what it says on Wikipedia because you'll
find out that I'm both a monster uh that
I'm bankrupted that I have no uh
background or backbone you'll find out
that I've B bedded everybody in the UK
many of those things won't actually be
true so just because you Googled
something that doesn't really make you
Elon mus darling does it it just means
maybe you can use use one or two of your
hands probably one side of your hand
more than the other it's had more
practice you then talk about zelen's
height as if that's a fact because you
read it and that's a misinterpretation
of itself isn't it because just because
you read it on Google doesn't make it
true my flower pot does it and then you
also talk about the fact this old
statistic Muslims 6% walk with me my
flower walk with me through London
through Lester through Birmingham
through Bradford and walk with me
through Minneapolis because you can call
it 6% if you make that disperate in a
population but in the cities where they
cluster together you will find they have
the majority it's why they have the
power it's why we have a Muslim mayor
it's why we have a Muslim Housing
Association it's why we have a Muslim
Police Association and it's why we have
Sharia law in most of our cities and
finally you managed to find a picture of
a police officer with a weapon well done
darling have a gold star and do some
more Googling maybe you could watch some
Cartoon Network while we adults talk of
course there are armed response officers
I said that as part of my answer but
most police officers on the streets of
the UK are not armed is that okay for
you yes my little flower pot so here's
the deal hold on you've managed wait
wait this is totally breaking wait you
need to stop the business stop value
tment because seriously what he's done
he's Googled police officers and they're
holding weapons which must make him
right and me wrong I'm literally came
here to talk out my ass but look what
he's done everybody I think that
deserves come on number one thank you
Tyler for Googling it on your end well
done done I I appreciate again I light
off with a compliment that you're a good
talker and you get eyeballs
congratulations you're good at that part
of the problem why you probably piss
people off is you have major masculine
energy so respect to you so I know
you're saying you're married I don't
know about that I know you're saying
that you've got you're a family woman
you
could but but Katie how can we trust
Google Katie I'm using your words
against you beautiful ask to pull your
little Winky and you can Google my
husband you probably have a bigger dick
than me Kati I don't know I'm packing
that will become a fact that will become
a fact if you go gu yeah but I don't
know if we can trust Google darling I
don't know so say no what was your what
was the point point is I'm giving you a
compliment you're hyperbolic you get
eyeballs respect I'm also saying not
everything you spew out there is
accurate what was the compliment that
you get eyeballs and that you're a good
talker I think if you're around for 15
or so years in the media it would be if
you were spewing nonsense you'd be
caught out quite no you'd probably be
cancelled everywhere and then where were
you canceled again I'm literally
cancelled from countries my darling okay
well is that a good thing are you proud
of that I am actually yes I am well then
kudos to you Katie I'm proud you're
doing what you want to do life I'm proud
of being deported from Australia for
going over there and calling out the
tyranny of lockdowns proud of standing
up for those people who had that done to
them and the Australians needed you you
like they needed Katie no and that's
something I always make very are you
even
Australian which are you even American
which question do you want me to answer
first the second there was three
actually are you question so I am not a
American I am not Australian okay and I
come over here because I'm a respectful
Foreigner and an outsider that cares
about your country so you're a globalist
no I'm not a globalist oh I don't know I
don't well I'm just like if you go and
like come to United States and and
basically get involved in or you go to
Australia get involved in politics I'm
not sure what you're doing I'm not sure
what you're doing I'm asking you genuine
questions and c I can't help but feel
you're kind of angry but I don't know
why maybe I woke up on the wrong side of
the bed today maybe I was I had a a
British girlfriend that you remind me of
I don't know however that's actually a
true story and by the way can we get him
Snickers bar or something know that's I
know get out of sers bar this morning I
know that's the true story I can feel
that Katie here's what I genuinely
believe here's what I genuinely believe
your believe me I date a lot hotter
chicks than you but here's what I
definitely believe you actually are a a
person that knows what they're doing
you're not an idiot you've been
confronted before you confront a lot of
people you've been you anti- liberalist
anti- Multicultural anti-fat
anti-immigrant anti- tattoos sorry uh to
inform you Vinnie she doesn't like you
you have tattoos okay so listen Katie
you're Cry Me a River she has a tattoo
on her okay there it is Katie she has a
tattoo on her bum Katie I've taken a lot
of heat before take it are you saying
you can't take heat Katie you take heat
all the time you give heat I just
there's just a lot of noise coming off
you I stop listen K I hear a lot of
noise you just sound a little more
proper than me Katie but we're all just
talking noise here I you're makit you're
making a bit of a thing of yourself
sweetie
just okay I thought this was so
interesting I have never seen Adam this
triggered I was like what did this woman
say and he does this to me sometimes
when I'm on his show he'll it's like a
backhanded way of saying you are just
making things up you're just saying
things to be shocking when sometimes the
truth is shocking he calls her a shock
jock
hyperbolic and then is constantly
Googling things to try to find anything
that proves what she's saying wrong um
Adam okay if you see this I live in
London all right I live here
please please I'll give you a tour I
look I don't even have an opinion on the
immigration stuff I'm not super po iCal
but what I thought was important about
this
clip sometimes you go into an interview
and the people are trying to understand
what you're saying and other times
they're just trying to discredit you the
entire time I don't know why he had this
agenda going in um but it is not 6% I
will give you a tour there are not
police officers with gun please come to
London please I'll give you a tour sorry
I was just laughing I was I was like
that is the funniest thing I've ever
heard um then he says you're a comedian
and you're just saying it to be a
comedian and my question is comedians
say things that are true and
uncomfortable and that's what makes it
funny so if we're going to do the
argument that she's saying things
because she's a
comedian I mean who tells more truth
than comedians in society then on top
then and this is what they do this to me
too and I hate it when they do this
you're like if you're getting into a
debate with somebody and you're going
back and forth A lot of times you go
into an interview you think it's good
faith and instead and this this has
happened to me they'll just bring up
everything you've ever said that they
disagree with and this this is what what
it's going to be and then so you'll try
to defend yourself and what they'll do
is they'll just say masculine energy
there's masculine energy but if you
don't defend yourself then you can't
even talk and you know that's what
that's what happens in the beginning she
she lets Adam talk he keeps interrupting
her she lets him talk and then she tries
to finish her sentence at the end and
then what does he what does he say
you're masculine you're masculine then
he says I date hotter chicks than you
I'm like this is the most inappropriate
I have ever seen a guest be treated so
the comment section actually love Katie
she says Katie Hopkins is the only funny
woman to ever
exist relying on Google for your talking
points is weak especially on P Beck
David's level I'm curious to what
Patrick actually thinks about this
exchange I think Patrick would liked
Katie he was laughing at her jokes he
embarrassed himself the whole time he
was triggered about something and tried
to make her look dumb but it didn't work
yeah no that's what he tried the other
thing that they I always see these talk
show hosts do they'll say you're just
spewing out because all right what
happens guys I'll tell you typically
when you've done hours and hours of
content and you've you have all of these
ideas there's a reason you come to these
conclusions I'll give you an
example when I first got into the red
pill like I started researching like red
pill content I wanted to hear where
where the guys were coming from I did
not understand why men did not want to
get married and so I would do a
show and um I'll give you an example I
was redpilled about abuse where I used
to think that women that were abused
were telling the truth typically until I
found out that most of these chicks were
lying because they don't file police
reports and yeah I just and really their
stories just didn't make any sense I was
like oh [__] they're lying I started to
get red pilled then because of that you
start to research different
stats and you look up what percent of
police reports are actually
filed against rape charges it's
something like seven eight% then you
start looking up more stats you start
thinking you start thinking of all of
these questions that you know people
just live their life dayto day they
wouldn't research it they wouldn't take
the time um it's not something they
really think about unless you've gone
through it and so to the average person
they might think you're just spewing out
nonsense but really it's just like hours
and hours and hours and hours and hours
of research and you have to back it up
anecdotally and I always say my opinions
number one come from anecdotes because
again Google can literally say anything
so personally I think our conclusions
really should come from real life first
and foremost the thing is guys we're
going down a dark path in society
because the powers that be that own
Google have the ability and the media
have the ability to manipulate our
thought processes they can say water is
wet the sky isn't blue or water is not
wet the sky isn't blue and literally
change the way people think and you know
guys that's why we see this craziness
today
that's why we see dark clouds gathering
as the market shutters stocks are
sinking currencies crumbling fear and
uncertainty reain in the Middle East
Ukraine Taiwan the debt it's endless yet
one asset stands firm gold in crisis
after crisis gold is there in the
background in its enduring value guards
against loss like a missile Shield
against incoming while paper wealth
Burns gold persists Shield your saving
against Lo looming threats War recession
and avoid the frenzied Panic of the
unprepared take control in the chaos
fortune favors decisive action get a
hold now of gold before it's Out Of
Reach right now Noble gold Investments
offers a free 5 ounce America the
Beautiful coin with every Ira claim your
free coin to secure your financial
future as this new storm gathers Panic
looms and some of the places that you
were thinking with your money well they
don't look so clever anymore secure your
future against um a against disaster
open a noble gold Investments IRA and
claim your free coin today go to
noblegold investments.com now that's
noblegold investments.com the only gold
company that I trust our last topic
today and this was the craziest topic
intha canoer 47 fatally poisoned her
boyfriend 51-year-old Stephen Edward
Riley Junior with anti-freeze after he
inherited 30 million on September 3rd
2023 he was feeling ill when he met his
lawyer she waited until the next day to
call Emergency Services then found Riley
unresponsive and was taken to bismar
hospital where he died September 5th due
to poisoning police arrested her on
October 30th charging her with class AA
felony murder heyer told investigators
she planned to split Riley's inheritance
with his son she also claimed she was
entitled to his fortune as his common
law wife however North Dakota doesn't
recognize such Rel relationships before
his death Riley wanted to break up with
her after getting his inheritance before
her arrest she proclaimed innocence on
Facebook and claimed Riley had killed
himself you're telling me a
man that just inherited 30 million was
going to kill
himself 30
million to the schaer that almost hit me
that's not married hello honey I wish I
was looking for someone but no I'm a one
man woman kind of person and Steve Riley
is the only man that I ever wanted that
was her post wow that is a women will
always find this woman killed a man and
women will still find a way to make it
about them uh the comment section says
she knew bro was FNA become a Serial
cheater she didn't even let him be a
millionaire for 24
hours just goes on to show what they're
really in it for can you
imagine losing 30 million in your life
over a woman that looks like this I mean
that's like the biggest L I've ever
heard of oh my gosh I would be so pissed
that's like you know but this is this
idea that women are not spiteful that
women are just these kind nurturing
people women are much more likely to
kill the innocent and the reason I keep
bringing this up is not to hate on women
because I'm I hate women and I'm trying
to just whatever it's because we have
all of this propaganda that tells us
that women would never do stuff like
this that women are special kind we have
these nurturing abilities or whatever it
was when really I believe that most evil
comes from spiteful women I actually
think that a lot of atrocities were
committed in the name of
women in the name of people's mothers I
mean women got the right to vote the
because of the OG Sim the deciding vote
on the 19th amendment was actually a guy
whose mom was a
suffragette you can't make this [__] up
and now we have a chick that literally
poisoned her boyfriend 24 hours after he
inherited $30 million that is
insane um but let me know what you guys
think in the comments and make sure you
leave a comment below as we read our
favorite comments at the end of the show
um today's top comment from last video
is my first experience with a woman in a
typically male job was a campground at
the age of 16 we worked as general labor
building things cutting Trails planting
trees and so on once or twice a week we
would rotate an easy day while we rode
the lawn mower basically just sitting on
our asses all day that'll ended when the
girl started she did nothing but ride
the lawn mower all day every day somehow
what was previously one to two days of
easy work became a full-time job for her
and the rest of us no longer got easy
days she never had a shovel hammer or
Axe and she got paid the same yes yes
and guys I genuinely believe that we are
stealing men's money because they take
money from the men and give it to us
even though we do less work but guys let
me know what you think in the comments
and make sure you like your favorite
comment below to vote for what comment
we read next time thank you for watching
and I'll talk to you you tomorrow